and so martin the first time that
cameras could witness a sentencing in a
criminal court in this case it's the old
bailey there in london
so talk us through what we heard we not
only got the sentencing but we also got
context around it some of the facts and
the reasoning for the sentencing
i think we got a lot more than even i
was expecting the point
of this exercise of opening up the court
to public scrutiny is to let
the public begin to understand
how sentences are arrived at and you
know in very bleak terms
judge sarah monroe went through in great
detail
how she had
first listened to the facts of the case
but then how she had assessed them
in determining what
the
what the sentence should be
now normally
the public would rely on court reporters
like me
and my colleagues
to report on what the judge said but of
course you know we don't have the space
in our newspapers or our tv bulletins
to give that kind of detail so that's
really what's changed in very very
dramatic terms today the public has been
able to listen to every word the judge
said and uh in theory we'll get a better
understanding of why
um this appalling crime did not merit um
the the guilty man being banged up for
the rest of his life um you know it is a
life sentence he will always be on
license if he should ever be freed but
some people
listening to the details the horrific
details
not only of his savage attack on his
grandfather but the abuse
and the mental issues that he had
suffered during his young life
so that should give people some
understanding why that that minimum term
was set at 10 years and eight months and
wasn't wasn't longer than that as i said
earlier the
key things for the judge to assess was
what she felt his level of
responsibility had been given his
history of abuse his mental health
issues his autistic spectrum disorder
and she said that you know of the three
options open to her to assess his
responsibility low medium and high she
felt he was at the latter end of the
medium
level of responsibility so that i think
early on was an indication of where she
might end up with the sentence she also
also talked about
the um aggravating factors
involved in his stabbing of his
grandfather
his grandfather's vulnerability remember
he was virtually bedridden he'd just
suffered a stroke
the level of physical injuries that were
inflicted in that stabbing attack 21
stab wounds to his face
seven to his body
and then she assessed the mitigation the
plea for mercy from his own lawyer
he'd always accepted his guilt he had
shown remorse he tried to get help for
his mental health issues and at the end
of the day the judge said she felt that
the mitigating factors the things on his
side outweighed the aggravating factors
so again
an indication how she arrived at that
sentence of a minimum sentence of ten
years and eight months but she did make
the very key point of course that she
felt having heard everything that he was
a dangerous individual and she had to
impose a life sentence um because of his
continuing significant risk to the
public um his continuing interest in the
illegal pornography and
the ferocity of his
attack on on his grandfather
martin thank you well let's bring in
former barrister and legal affairs
journalist
catherine baxi now so catherine it was a
difficult watch at that sentencing but
why is it considered so important for
members of the public to be able to
witness a sentencing live from a
criminal call like this well as the
judge said there this was a very complex
sentencing exercise and she took 20
minutes roughly to explain
the facts of the case the horrendous
background to
the man's life and the background to the
killing
if
the public only see a snippet of a
report on the the news or in in the
newspapers
they may not fully understand the reason
behind her sentence so today
this move hopefully will enable the
public to understand the reasons why
people are sentenced to to the sentences
they get because if if you just see the
headline sentence uh 10 years and uh
eight months you might think oh why
wasn't he why didn't he get a longer
sentence but having heard the very
detailed background that the judge went
into it
explains exactly uh the the pros and
cons the mitigation the aggravation the
sentencing guidelines uh the evidence
that that's been considered and
hopefully it should help the public to
to understand uh the reasons behind
sentences and it opens up the the
criminal courts to to greater scrutiny
and but most importantly to the
understanding um behind the sentencing
process
have always been open to the public
haven't they i mean the problem is there
aren't that many seats and not many
people can get into the cases that they
want to see but i guess this is an
extension of that this sense of justice
being seen to be done yeah absolutely it
brings the sentencing process into
people's sitting rooms most people don't
go to courts to look at sentencing they
don't know
where to find out about judgments so
this this brings it right into their
homes uh it is an extension of of moves
that have already been going on in in
scotland um
uh television of of broadcasting of of
trials has been permissible since uh
1992. the supreme court since its
foundation in 2010 um has been broadcast
and the court of appeal
hearings have also been televised
since
2013.
and it's it's almost 10 years since the
government
promised that this broadcast of
sentencing hearings would happen they
first suggested it in 2013 uh so it's
it's been a long time coming uh
fought for by um broadcast organizations
including sky uh so it's it's a very
positive move and that um sentencing
exercise which we've just seen uh the
judge was very very clear and detailed
and if that's what it's going to be like
uh
it should uh go some way to improving
understanding only the most senior uh
judges will be able to
give permission for their uh sentencing
hearings to be filmed either high court
judges sitting in the crown court or
senior
circuit judges and resident judges
so at the minute it's limited it's
limited there and it's limited to to
certain courts so it is it does open the
door uh to the the criminal courts a
little more